Leistung ist ihr Schicksal. Spitzensportler
bauen ihre Karriere
spätestens seit dem Teenageralter Schritt für
Schritt auf.
Ich bin Bente Pflug, 29 Jahre alt, komme aus
Berlin
und bin seit dem zehnten Lebensjahr
Eisschnellläuferin.
Berlin: Vier- bis fünfmal die Woche trainiert
sie für ihren Sport.
Bente Pflug war schon bei den Olympischen
Spielen 2014 dabei.
Über 3.000 und 5.000 Meter wurde sie jeweils
Elfte.
Jedes Jahr aufs Neue muss man sich
beweisen
– auch in relativ jungen Jahren schon. Man
kämpft um Kaderstatus,
um finanzielle Unterstützung, die dann
dadurch dranhängt und ...
Ja, das lernt man über die Jahre kennen. Und
man lernt es auch immer mehr zu schätzen.
Und es wird halt, je älter man wird und je
höher der Leistungsdruck wird,
in welchem Bereich man dann unterwegs ist,
einfach immer härter.
Der Leistungsdruck ist Teil des Geschäfts.
Wer Zeiten nicht schafft,
fliegt raus aus Nationalkadern und verliert
finanzielle Förderungen.
Wegen einer schweren Knieverletzung
schaffte sie es nicht
zu Olympia 2018 nach Pyeongchang.
Auch ihr Status als Sportsoldatin wackelte
während ihrer Verletzungszeit.
Sportpsychologin Franziska Wenhold kennt
die Probleme der Athleten.
Ohne Kaderstatus würdest du da auch den
Status der Sportsoldatin verlieren.
Das ist natürlich schwierig, ne, weil du ja
weiter trainierst, ja.
Also, das ist nicht so einfach.
Du kannst Soldatin bleiben, ne, aber der
Status Sportsoldat,
wo du sozusagen freigestellt wirst, ja, für dein
Training,
das ist dann nicht mehr so einfach.
Ohne Leistung also keine Förderung: Bei den
deutschen Meisterschaften 2018
in Inzell wurde sie aber über 5.000 Meter
schon wieder Dritte.
Wie schafft man es aus so einem Tal wieder
heraus?
Und dann habe ich mir ein sehr, sehr gutes
Umfeld geschaffen mit Rehabilitationstrainerin
am Olympiastützpunkt hier und
Mentaltrainerin, meine[r] Familie, meinem
Heimtrainer.
Und alle haben mir zur Seite gestanden, und
wir haben gesagt: „Wir schaffen das.“
Dabei ist Leistungsdruck kein Hindernis,
sondern wird als Werkzeug verstanden.
Sportpsychologen arbeiten deswegen mit
Athleten an Bewältigungsstrategien.
Dieses Druckempfinden ist sozusagen
förderlich, ist ’ne Ressource, die ich habe.
Und dementsprechend kann ich dann auch
auf den Punkt kommen, ne.
Wenn eine Athletin in meiner Beratung mal
gesagt hat:
„Ich bin immer so aufgeregt vor wichtigen
Ereignissen, dass ich fast kotzen muss“,
da hab ich gesagt: „Herzlichen Glückwunsch,
weil ohne diese Aufregung wirst du keine
Olympiasiegerin.“
Bente Pflugs neues altes Ziel sind die
Olympischen Spiele, diesmal 2022 in Peking.
Es wird wohl ihre letzte Chance sein,
dann mit 32 Jahren vielleicht doch noch eine
olympische Medaille zu gewinnen.
Man muss verrückt sein, um
Leistungssportler zu sein, glaube ich.
Also ich denke, die wenigsten ganz ruhigen
Typen kommen so an die Spitze.
Man muss schon verrückt sein und man muss
Durchhaltevermögen haben.
Dabei ist Leistungsdruck im Eisschnelllauf
noch einigermaßen überschaubar.
In anderen Sportarten wie Fußball geht es
noch viel intensiver zur Sache.
Es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen
den Sportarten, ob ich im Profibereich
unterwegs bin oder ob ich
in diesem Bereich Leistungssport
und Kader … Bundeskadersport bin.
Die Profisportler, die bauen ja ’ne Karriere auf
um den Sport
und wollen mit dem Sport Geld verdienen.
Das heißt, sie gucken nicht, ob sie parallel
noch eine berufliche Karriere aufbauen.
Und darauf setzt auch Bente Pflug, die
parallel Grundschulpädagogik studiert,
später also Lehrerin werden möchte.
Im Leistungssport gibt’s so viele schöne
Sachen,
aber auch viele Sachen, die man entbehrt,
glaub ich.
Und das sind einfach Sachen, die dann
irgendwann,
wenn ich mal nicht am Heiligabend vielleicht
früh um neun
hier auf dem Eis stehen muss, dann sage ich:
„Ach, ist das schön.“
Leistungsdruck im Spitzensport
ist eine wichtige Triebfeder,
wenn er gut kanalisiert wird
– und das beweisen Athleten wie Bente Pflug
regelmäßig.